[Music]
we interrupt this commercial break to
bring you one of the most mind-bending
horror films of 2018 and no I don't mean
a Christmas Prince to Hulu's puka is a
bizarre and insanely enjoyable horror
film from Blum house part 3 of its into
the dark series and of course at being
December puka centers around Christmas
so in this video we're gonna break down
all the details to not only explain the
ending but find out who puka is and a
lot more interesting goodies that are
easy to miss the film starts off where
it ends
flashing red-and-blue lights and a puka
doll amongst the flames of a wreckage
we'll later find out is a car crash a
voice which will later find out as
Melanie's repeats the phrase look at all
the pretty lights the same phrase she
tells ty in the car just before the
crash a phrase which the Puka dog
remembers and repeats over and over when
it malfunctions due to the crash and
it's also the same phrase the
malfunctioning puka dolls repeat which
forces them to be recalled we get our
first glimpse of Wilson and Klaus our
protagonist whose last name which is
only spoken once in the film sounds
eerily similar to Klaus or Claus Santa
Claus the red and blue lights illuminate
his face as the camera does this weird
movement almost suggesting he's laying
on the pavement and then turns upright
bonus points if you noticed he's wearing
the same outfit here in the beginning as
he does in the end the red and blue
lights play a prominent role throughout
the film and essentially signify two
things red violence and anger and blue
happiness and pleasure this is easily
seen when the pooka doll's eyes turn red
when he's naughty and blue when he's
nice but more subtly is how the director
and cinematographer play with lighting
throughout the course of the movie when
Wilson leaves his apartment and hears
the neighbors music blaring the same
music which we hear in the car radio at
the end by the way her end of the
hallway is red red also signifies danger
and it's only fitting that his
neighbor's name happens to be red the
walls of her apartment are even painted
all red and they both live on the 7th
floor which if you're going by Dante's 7
circles of hell
number seven is violence later on in the
film the red lights
become more apparent here in the bar the
backyard of Melanie's behind him in his
own apartment the red hallway the tree
market and finally in the background
when Melanie utters the line look at all
the pretty lights before the crash blue
is equal parts as important but doesn't
show up as frequently blue signifies
happiness and is more evident early on
especially when Wilson is courting
Melanie Winnie jerks off as puka his
eyes are blue but is surrounded by
smaller red lights that of passion but
as we continue the story we find Wilson
down on his luck he's a struggling actor
having newly moved to the city and is
desperately alone but that's all about
to change with the introduction of puka
Wilson recites lines for Charles
Dickens's A Christmas Carol for an
upcoming audition in essence puka is a
modern twist on this story about a man
who has serious shortcomings like a
Christmas carols Ebenezer Scrooge but by
seeing what he's caused and what will
happen to him he changes for the better
this story is told by using the past
present and future just like how a
beanie zur was visited by the ghosts of
Christmas past present and future
Wilson's past whoever involves meeting
Melanie at the open house you can even
tell by the date here October that it's
not even close to Christmas when he
first meets her he talks about how he'd
furnished the room with a big leather
chair and abstract art and guess what
when we see him in the present his home
has been adorned with a leather chair
and abstract art Wilson does get his job
as puka and it takes off allowing him
enough money to eventually buy his home
and move in with Melanie and tie we know
he was likely very successful as an
actor judging by this photo here of him
on the red carpet this success whoever
got to his head in and became more and
more temperamental which we also see in
the film as he gets increasingly angry
toward Melanie eventually culminating in
him slapping a boy at Ty's birthday
party for making fun of his son Melanie
asked him to leave and he does but comes
crawling back asking for a second chance
and this is where we get into the
present this is the moment where
everything can change when Melanie
either decides to take Wilson Mack or
not
Wilson even tells her not to listen to
alternate Wilson because he's learned
how terrible he is and this is also the
key moment in Wilson's journey as our
protein
honest he's learned the error of his
ways by going through this journey and
does not want to become what the future
might hold
just like how Scrooge decides to change
after seeing what will happen to him
but with Wilson he has a literal killing
of the old self in the scene where he
chops the burning puka with an axe it is
the physical representation of him
killing his old self
an old self that let fame success in his
anger get the best of him it's only by
killing this part of him can he see the
error of his ways become a new man and
changed the future so it's no surprise
that when Wilson sees the confrontation
between Melanie and alternate Wilson
he tells Melanie not to trust him but
she does anyway and this is important
because Wilson's journey isn't
completely over he must confront the
worst thing that could possibly happen
to him his heart of darkness and he'll
see this in his future the death of his
wife and child
this is the final moment where he'll
truly learn that family is more
important than money or fame Puka our
Christmas Carol ghost here is like the
ghost of Christmas future showing him
the future standing by his side and just
like in Dickens Tale he doesn't speak
and perhaps the reason both pukka and
the ghost of Christmas future don't
speak is to show how Wilson has the
freewill to change the future while the
past can't be changed and the present is
occurring the future is still unknown it
is yet to be written
this is also a good time to mention that
puka is derived from the Irish word puka
for spirit or ghost it's a creature from
Celtic folklore considered to be the
bringer of both good or bad fortune they
could take the shape of animals such as
a hare and in our case it looks just
like that with a pretty big exception
the eyes and mouth resembled that of a
front car hinting at the eventual car
crash but let's take a moment to discuss
read the driver of the other vehicle
this crash wasn't just Wilson's fault
for speeding notice here the speed limit
of 35 but it was also Reds alcoholism if
you remember when the detective finds
red having jumped from the apartment he
calls it a suicide that it was the
bottle that got to her and even in the
first scene where red welcomes Wilson
into his apartment early in the morning
she asks him if he wants a drink more
tragic are the pictures of her and her
daughter on the mantle the daughter she
herself killed in the accident she even
says
she feared being alone for Christmas
until Wilson arrived remember though
that all these memories are jumbled and
some are out of place and don't make
sense that's the point look how the
pooka producer is also a paramedic
Wilson meets at the end and there's no
better indication of this than the guy
I'll simply refer to as the family man
now this is easy to miss but also quite
interesting in the beginning of the film
at the coffee shop Wilson has asked if
he could take a picture for this family
take a look at this guy here it's the
same guy who Wilson will later ask to
take a picture with his family but it
doesn't stop there
guess who's interviewed about the pooka
recalls the family man and who beats up
Wilson on the street later same guy he
also asks if there was a struggle
outside the apartment where red
committed suicide and now I'm not a
hundred percent sure on this one since I
couldn't get a good look but he could
also be the other paramedic at the end
here Wilson's mind is a jumbled mess
where some things are remembered and
some things aren't just like how the
producer said the pooka doll decides
what things are remembered and what
aren't that's why the timeline in this
film is tough to follow and sometimes
doesn't make any sense but behind all
this mystery and what some may find an
ambiguous ending I found a beautiful
story about one man's acknowledgement of
the past to change himself for the
better I hope you enjoyed this ending
explained video please make sure to LIKE
subscribe and share I make a ton of
different types of videos like this and
I hope you'll check it out and I'll be
coming out with more in the future for
all my fans who know how I like to end
my videos remember daddy loves you very
much